cbs news senior political analyst and 60
minutes correspondent that's john
dickerson
joins us to discuss john this is a thing
always good to see you of course but
this is the thing you're the perfect
person for this conversation
i think if why the words are so hard
because you hear in february where he
knew how deadly it was a president
then you see that he's out on the
campaign trail saying something very
different nothing to
see here no big deal i keep thinking
about people who died during that time
and people who have lost loved ones on
the other hand
the president's supporters say listen
he's supposed to be a cheerleader which
is what the president said he was doing
he doesn't want to cause panic he wants
to keep calm
do his supporters have a point about his
strategy here
no gail there's a clear playbook when
there's a public health crisis if you
read
any of the manuals for leaders in a
public health crisis
it says the most important thing is to
be truthful to people
you have to tell them the truth because
in this case if you're not truthful to
people
you send them out into the world and
they make the situation worse
they spread it so to suggest that not
sowing panic is a viable leadership
option when you've got a pandemic
that spreads through contact is not
possible but secondly
and this is really important because
telling the truth here is crucial to
public health the president is
mischaracterizing how he handled
the virus in its early period he was
saying that
talk of the virus and its virulence was
a democratic plot and something that the
media was raising and he called it
he called well he the hoax language is a
little tricky but
but what he certainly did was he said it
was the democrats who were raising it
and the media and the reason that's
important
is he is diminishing the warnings so
he's not just saying
don't be fearful but he's saying when
you hear somebody saying this is
something to be fearful about
you should be suspicious of them that
sows mistrust and distrust
into future warnings about this as it
goes forward
so it's much worse than not sowing panic
it's actively undermining the public
health response
so what does it say about his leadership
during times like this
well it says that in a crucial period he
did
not follow what we would expect leaders
to do and
specifically what we would expect
leaders to do in a public health crisis
and again telling the truth is so
crucial because
if you don't tell the truth at the
beginning not only do the cases snowball
but then people don't trust you when
future decisions have to be made and
they have to listen to you
amanda ripley wrote a book about
disasters and what leaders do in a
disaster and the first thing that they
all say
is tell people the truth even if it's an
unpleasant truth
turns out people can handle it and when
you tell them the truth it binds them
all together
so there's a playbook for this you tell
them the truth and that sets the
conditions for all the other hard truths
they're going to have to
hear from you and finally why are people
distrustful about vaccines right now
because they've been fed a steady diet
of mistruths
including yesterday from the white house
podium in which the president's
press secretary said he never downplayed
it well there are
32 cases of downplaying it from the
washington post count and the president
himself admitted it so
the ongoing lack of trust creates a bad
situation not in the past but in this
very moment well there certainly is a
lot of chatter about it john i was
watching
news last night i stayed up very late
watching all the all the coverage
one it's being compared to the watergate
tapes and to a smoking gun do you think
it rises to that level
well as an abstract matter of
presidential leadership
and why is this matter the president's
key job is keeping everybody safe
this isn't just one bad decision in the
heat of the moment this is a protracted
choice
over a long period of time while the
stakes were as high as they were
they could possibly be to not inform the
public
in the way it needed to be informed so
it's a this is about as big a decision
as possible what's different now though
than
during watergate is that we don't think
about things in the abstract we are
in a condition and we're in the middle
of a presidential campaign where
everybody is off on their to their sides
and there as we've seen again and again
been very little interest on the
president's side
to say anything that's critical of him
particularly now when it's a
presidential race where the stakes are
high
there's not that pressure on the
president that richard nixon had
when a lot of republicans came to him
and said you've got to resign
all right john thank you very much good
to see you and a reminder covet 19 is
still thriving everybody it is still
very much
with us bob woodward's first broadcast
interview about the revelations in his
new book will air this sunday on 60
minutes
he tells scott palette scott pelley his
name hasn't changed
what he learned from his nine hours of
interviews with president trump and
we will be speaking with bob woodward
next tuesday live right here on cbs this
morning really looking forward to that